wen rechnet ihr die besten chancen an
wer wäre auch der beste für den job und
natürlich carina ladies first was denkst
du
wäre morgen die richtige entscheidung
und auch die entscheidung gefallen wird
also die antwort wäre auf jeden fall
nicht die gleiche weil ich rechne
norbert röttgen nicht die besten chancen
aus aber aus meiner sicht wäre er der
beste kandidat um die cdu wirklich auch
in den nächsten jahren erfolgreich zu
halten oder noch erfolgreicher zu machen
er ist modern weltgewandt liberal und es
ist ja auch später immer eine rolle
welches image
jemand hat und was jemand ausstrahlt was
jemand verkörpert und wenn man so an
friedrich merz denkt denkt man so ein
bisschen an die männerpartei cdu aus den
80er jahren so breitbeinig
kraftstrotzend und ego first bei armin
laschet das ist so ein bisschen die
mutti in männlich also immer auf
kompromiss aus versöhnung integrierend
alle seiten mit einbeziehen aber am ende
fragt man sich wofür steht eigentlich so
und norbert röttgen bringt meiner
meinung nach wirklich so den perfekten
mix an profil mit also liberal in der
gesellschaftspolitik aber konservativ in
sachen sicherheitspolitik
er hat ganz klar stellung bezogen zum
beispiel beim thema abschiebungen von
gefährdern eben auch nach nordsyrien und
eine ambitionierte klimapolitik
ambitionierte digital politik und da
muss ich sagen er kommt zudem noch ganz
gut bei frauen an was man so hört besser
als die anderen beiden kandidaten und
frauen sind ja auch wenn sie jetzt bei
den delegierten nur ein drittel
ausmachen und in der partei selbst auch
nur eine minderheit unter der
wählerschaft durchaus eine kraft und
deswegen wird ich sage aus der
perspektive der cdu wer so norbert
röttgen der wirklich für aufbruch und
erneuerung steht die beste wahl
1001 delegierten stimmen darüber ab wer
denkst du es der richtige für den job
also der liebling der basis ist ganz
klar friedrich merz es gab dutzende
abstimmung in kreisverbänden in
landesverbänden sogar und in großen
vereinigung die junge union hat sich
hinter märz gestellt
die mittelstandsvereinigung hat sich
hinter märz gestellt nicht sehr
überraschend aber immerhin und sehr
viele kleine kreisverbände also der
liebling der basis ist ganz klar
friedrich merz
und sowohl die wirtschaftskompetenz die
im zuge der arkona krise natürlich von
großer wichtigkeit ist dürfte für sein
punktekonto ausschlaggebend sein
und hinzu kommt etwas was in baden
württemberg gerade von schäuble unter
anderem internen immer wieder
kommuniziert wird am ende einer ära
eines starken kanzlers muss es einen
wechsel geben der nicht nur den wechsel
ist von beifahrersitz als lenkrad
sondern es muss sich etwas ändern was
sich sichtbar zeigt aber eben auch
inhaltlich und auch im stil merkel hat
damals einen brief geschrieben um die
ära kohl krachend zu beenden
da wäre glaube ich märz derjenige der am
stärksten ohne es wirklich betonen zu
müssen sagt okay wir beginnen jetzt
etwas neues das kann armin laschet gar
nicht der ja ganz klar betont dass er
für kontinuität ist und bei röttgen ist
es halt auch schwierig weil er eine
längere geschichte im kabinett merkel
hat und mit merkel zusammen da wäre märz
wahrscheinlich die verkörperung dieses
neue aufbruchs deshalb rechne ich ihm
ganz gute chancen aus am ende in einer
stichwahl weiß man nie wohin die stimmen
wandern vor ort kennen ja rausgeflogen
ist bei ihr als erster und einziger
wirklich von ihr entlassen wurden also
ich glaube so ganz dringend mit ihr in
verbindung gebracht hätte man doch nicht
er hat bewiesen dass er weiß wie man
wahlen verliert insofern bin ich nicht
sicher ob das ein gutes erfahrungsräume
sie darauf steht wir wollen jetzt
natürlich auch noch von paul wissen in
deinen augen wer sollte ab morgen ak
beerben wer ist der richtige für den job
also ich kann das natürlich auch nur mit
perspektive der cdu beantworten ich
persönlich habe da keinen favoriten
sondern wenn man das betrachtet was es
für die partei das beste
ich glaube es erst mal falsch sorge ralf
aber die ära kohl mit der ära merkel in
der form zu vergleichen weil kohl wurde
abgewählt merkel ist noch da
wahrscheinlich wenn sie wieder antreten
würde würde sie sogar noch mal
wiedergewählt
zu dem zeitpunkt stand die cdu in
umfragen viel schlechter da im vergleich
als heute das so zu sagen diejenigen die
sich der merkel politik zugehörig fühlen
haben immer noch große große
unterstützung und deswegen halte ich es
für einen fehler sich sozusagen radikal
abzuwenden insbesondere in die
im jahr wo die krise so groß geschrieben
ist wo corona so eine wichtige bedeutung
hat und wo man ja gar nicht weiß wie die
wahl dann am ende aussieht und stichwort
wahl da glaube ich eben nicht dass
automatisch derjenige der jetzt hier
gewählt wird auch kanzlerkandidat sein
muss aber wenn wir sozusagen über den
vorsitzenden sprechen dann denke ich
dass verkörpert armin laschet das ist
der der immer unterschätzt wurde keiner
hat ihm zugetraut
nrw ministerpräsident zu werden wenn
jemand hat mir mal erzählt ich weiß
nicht so wirklich ob das stimmt aber
selbst seine frau aktien kaum zugetraut
dass er ministerpräsident werden würde
er aber natürlich augenzwinkernd aber
das war sozusagen symbolisch dafür dass
er so ein bisschen immer derjenige war
wo man gedacht hat
das wird dass das passiert nichts so
aber er hat jetzt in nrw eine wahnsinnig
gute arbeit geleistet
er hat das anerkannte ministerpräsident
hat hohe beliebtheitswerte
er steht für eine koalition mit der fdp
dem klassischen bündnis das heißt er
käme tatsächlich aus einer position der
stärke heraus und könnte einerseits
sozusagen die wähler mitnehmen die der
kanzlerin noch nahe stehen und dennoch
auch für ein bisschen aufbau und
veränderung sorgen was man sozusagen von
ak erwartet hatte wo sie enttäuscht hat
ich glaube dass armin laschet dadurch
dass sein 16 millionen bundesland
regiert da auch ein ganz anderes
auftreten hat auch direkt eine andere
mal ein anderes machtzentrum in der
partei hätte eines muss man sagen man
seine beliebtheitswerte sich anschaut
also wenn man sozusagen jetzt darauf
schaut was macht das mit armin laschet
also wird er sozusagen dann auch
kanzlerkandidat das ist die offene frage
und das könnte so zu sagen vielleicht
auch so ein bisschen ein bonuspunkt für
ihn seien sogar bei den delegierten
nämlich die frage kann man sich mit der
personalie laschet die sozusagen die cdu
dann führt einen kanzlerkandidaten soda
vorstellen so das denke ich ist durchaus
möglich
und ich glaube das ist bei merz reifen
weist das besser aber eher weniger
möglich denn
was man so hört oder was diskutiert wird
ist das märz in jedem fall
kanzlerkandidat werden will
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
weil bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren